c'était il trompé de campagne les
adversaires de françois bayrou lui
reprocher de profiter du scrutin
européen pour faire campagne pour la
présidentielle de 2012
aujourd'hui ce sont de ses propres rangs
que montrent les critiques et surtout
beaucoup s'interrogent sur le choix fait
par le président du modem en toute fin
de campagne d'attaqués son principal
concurrent daniel cohn bendit sur un
terrain très personnelle caroline de
chater aujourd'hui au siège du modem
françois bayrou est resté invisible et
la défaite s'avère très indigeste
déjà hier soir le président du mouvement
centriste et rester enfermé deux heures
dans son bureau avant de s'exprimer
devant les militants une déclaration aux
accents de mea culpa je prends ma part
de responsabilité dans une campagne très
dure je ne suis pas parvenu à faire
passer le message auquel j'étais attaché
je me suis laissé entraîner dans une
polémique excessive qui a troublé mais
au sein même du modem est des voix
s'élèvent pour remettre en cause sa
stratégie de campagne fondée sur son
opposition systématique à nicolas
sarkozy il ya eu une trop grande
médiatisation autour de lui ce qui fait
que nous avons donné l'impression et
elle était largement alimenté aussi par
un certain nombre de ses adversaires
ancien ami que le modem c'était françois
bayrou tout seul et comme la
communication s'est faite
essentiellement sur son livre
effectivement on a très peu parlé
d'europe
françois bayrou un brin trop nombriliste
la question est écarté par ses fidèles
de plantes qui préfère montrer du doigt
l'abstention et le vote apolitique c'est
comme ça qu'en europe écologie
d'ailleurs a réuni beaucoup suffrages au
fond sur la politique c'est un vote
citoyen je les qualifiés tels que je
crois que c'est assez juste c'est pas un
vote de parti politique c'est un vote
partisan au fond ça c'est pour une
partie des gens qui ont voté
et puis
il faut noter que 60 % de nos
compatriotes ne sont même pas allés
voter
un an après sa défaite aux municipales
de porc le président du modem doit faire
face à un nouveau camouflet
le troisième homme de la présidentielle
devenu le quatrième des européennes ne
brille plus sous les feux de la rampe